[Musique]
on a choisi le modèle de l'alternance
pour pour pour deux raisons la première
c'est que nous ne souhaitions pas acquis
et de barrières financières à l'entrée
on souhaitait répondre à un besoin
urgent de compétences des entreprises
[Musique]
toutes les entreprises aujourd'hui
quelle que soit la taille des
entreprises puisque une tpe
malheureusement des tpe se font aussi
attaqué et c'est dramatique ou des pme
pour lesquelles c'est dramatique aussi
jusqu'aux grands groupes effectivement
tous secteurs confondus on va former des
experts en cybersécurité c'est à dire
des gens qui vous vont à la fois
comprendre les besoins de production de
l'industrie mais avec ce souci de caisse
que potentiellement peut mal se passer
et être exploitées à des fins
malveillantes
[Musique]